I think for me it became an issue of  when I saw it just deeply irresponsible  medical professionals that exist I don't  know why a minor would need Top surgery  for other reasons I mean I would have to  look into the details of what happened  outside the window of gender dysphoria  that would require you to do that but  any type of permanent surgery and then I  know some people say oh just get breast  implants then yeah that's not healthy I  mean that is not a healthy alternative  to say to someone we're going to chop  your breasts off because you decide at  15 that you think you're a different  gender and your parents go along with it  and it's all fine and dandy and then  you're disfigured and then you will get  breast implants 20 years later that's  not a solution